It had been one month since the end of the
world.
30 long days since Stella had watched her
husband dissolve in front of her, one minute
mowing the lawn like it was any other lazy
afternoon, and the next collapsing into a
useless pile of flesh and jelly.
The end didn’t come like she always thought
it would, with hellfire raining down and pale
riders galloping across the land on horseback.
It began in the kitchen with her humming a
song to herself, mixing up a pitcher of lemonade
before she rejoined her family in the sunshine.
Then they were gone, lost forever when the
sun turned wrong.
She didn’t even have time to grieve them
properly before the threat turned on her,
as the creatures that had once been her husband,
her son, and her daughter swarmed the door,
slamming their new bodies against the wood
with wet slaps, calling out to her in warped
voices begging her to step back outside.
She covered her ears and wept for hours until
she had no tears left to cry.
It didn’t take long for Stella to figure
out that, whatever had happened to her family,
it was happening all over the world.
The small town she had known and loved had
transformed into a hellscape, a maze of monsters
and deadly light.
She retreated underground, to old mine shafts
and tunnels, left abandoned decades ago when
the local coal trade had dried up.
There, she quickly discovered that she wasn’t
the only one with that idea.
There were others, survivors who had managed
to make their way down into the dark, away
from the horrors above.
There weren’t many, and she could never
get too attached to the ones she did meet
in case they too were lost to the sun, but
as the days wore on in the tunnels she found
herself forming a small group of stragglers.
Not quite a family, but something that could
be one day, and definitely much better than
going it alone.
There was Stella, of course, using her background
as an elementary school teacher to keep everyone
on track and working together.
Then there was Brian, a former volunteer firefighter
whose training and skills with an axe came
in handy more than once.
There was Trina, a teenage girl who had been
babysitting when everything went to hell,
who had a knack for evading the flesh monsters
and making supply runs.
And then there was Doris, former military
nurse, and current de facto team medic, sharp
and capable in spite of being in her late
70s.
They were brave people, brilliant, and refused
to give up.
Others came and went, spare survivors they
picked up as they navigated their way, raiding
the ruins of grocery stores and hospitals,
but they always wound up leaving again.
Or, worse, something would go wrong and the
sunlight would claim another victim.
But the four of them stayed together, stronger
with their combined skills, willpower, and
ability to sleep in shifts and keep an eye
out for trouble.
After some time in the tunnels, the group
had come across a massive abandoned facility.
None of them could determine where it came
from, or what organization might have run
it, but it appeared to have been some kind
of research lab.
It was isolated, cut off from outside influences
better than any of their previous hideouts
had been.
Whoever had once worked here had cleared out
- or been taken out - in a hurry, but in their
place, they had left behind rations, medical
equipment, emergency generators, and clean
drinking water.
There were enough supplies to keep the group
going for months, if they rationed carefully.
And so, they settled in.
The abandoned research facility, whatever
it once was, became their makeshift home.
This unexpected sanctuary was cut off from
the rest of the world.
Clinical, cold, lonely, but a safe place for
them to rest their heads.
Now, it had been a month since this all began.
Stella shook her head at this realization,
the passage of time feeling almost meaningless
at this point.
What did a month even mean anymore?
What was a day when she couldn’t even see
the sun rise and set?
As she sat there, warming herself by the side
of a foraged space heater, she thought about
missing the stars, the moon, the promise of
the cosmos.
A time when the vast, open sky was an invitation
to dream, instead of something to hide from.
That time was gone now.
There was nothing to do but mourn it and carry
on.
If not for her, then for the others.
They had all found ways to keep busy in this
new place.
Trina took to exploring the empty halls, the
laboratories filled with strange equipment,
the small rooms that looked like prison cells
or police interrogation rooms.
She had cooked up some theory about it being
a government facility, like something out
of an old episode of The X Files.
Brian had found an on-site library, filled
with history books and scientific texts.
There was enough to read in there, he said,
that by the time he was finished he would
have the equivalent of several doctorate degrees.
Doris had taken initial stock of all of the
medical supplies available at the site, gauze,
disinfectant, vials upon vials of medications
she had never even heard of, and had categorized
them all neatly.
Now, she spent her hours mostly sitting with
Stella, telling her stories about whatever
she felt like.
Her time overseas, her late husband, their
children, decades-old neighborhood gossip.
It felt good to talk, no matter what it was
about.
It felt human.
They all had their ways of keeping a grip
on their own humanity.
It had almost gotten boring, holed up in the
facility without the constant threat of danger
pressing in from all sides.
Boring, but peaceful.
Stella could feel herself starting to nod
off, her eyelids sagging, her dinner of canned
beans sitting heavy in her stomach.
Next to her, Doris had already begun to softly
snore.
Soon, sleep would come for her too, and bring
with it dreams, memories of the life that
was gone forever, the world as she had once
known it.
The dreams were tough, but waking up from
them was even tougher.
Still, she had to rest.
She could only fight it for so long.
She could almost hear her husband’s voice,
when…
“Hey, Stella?
You might want to see this.”
Brian was there, suddenly, his words breaking
through the haze in her mind.
His tone was severe, and she knew that sleep
would have to wait.
She followed him down the hall for a while,
before he stopped and turned her attention
to a section of damaged wall.
It was rusted and corroded, black and grey
with massive cracks in the solid material.
It looked like it had been slowly disintegrated
over time by an incredibly strong acid.
It was off-putting to look at, giving off
the distinct sense that something bad had
happened.
But a lot of bad things had happened in the
past month.
“I don’t really understand what I’m
looking at,” Stella said, and Brian grabbed
her by the shoulders, commanding her attention.
“This wasn’t here yesterday.
Hell, it wasn’t here a few hours ago.”
He gestured to the damage.
“It just happened.
And whatever is responsible?
Is probably still here.”
A chill ran down Stella’s spine.
It seemed impossible for this kind of structural
damage to happen over the course of a few
hours.
She could see twisted steel rebar, drips of
melted metal that had trickled onto the floor.
As she leaned in for a closer look, she gagged.
There was an overpowering stench of rot and
decay.
It didn’t take long for her to spot the
source: a thick, black mucus covered the hole
in the wall, slick and slimy and giving off
the putrid smell.
It wasn’t like the material that made up
the flesh creatures outside, it was something
else entirely.
Something she had never seen before.
She reached out a hand to touch it, but quickly
caught herself.
Whatever this stuff was, it was bad news.
If it could do that to a solid wall, she didn’t
even want to think about what it could do
to flesh and bone.
“What do we do?”
She asked.
“Inspect the area, make sure it’s safe.
See if it’s some kind of toxic waste leak,
or…”
He didn’t finish the thought.
He didn’t have to.
They needed to find out if this damage came
from something living, something that could
be hiding in the building with them and waiting
for the chance to strike.
When they returned to the main room, Doris
was awake and Trina was there waiting for
them.
They agreed to split into pairs and search
the facility, looking for any additional damage,
strange black fluid, or signs of foul play
of any kind.
Trina and Brian went one way, while Doris
and Stella went the other, each person armed
with a flashlight and a weapon of some kind.
An axe, a bat, a knife.
Stella had found a loaded pistol when they
first arrived, one that she hoped she would
never have to use.
Now, she carried it with her.
Just in case.
Stella and Doris walked together for an hour,
keeping an eye out for anything suspicious.
They didn’t find anything notable, really.
There were some bits of rust they hadn’t
seen before, an occasional black puddle pooling
on the floor, but nothing like the scene Brian
had found.
As they walked in silence, Stella felt herself
begin to relax.
Maybe the worst was over, maybe a pipe had
broken somewhere and broken down a bit of
the wall, but nothing else would really come
of it.
Then, from the other side of the building,
there came a high-pitched scream.
She knew that voice immediately.
Trina, screaming bloody murder, and Brian
bellowing something.
She grabbed Doris by the arm, and the two
ran in the direction of the sound.
As they got closer, they could hear other
sounds in addition to Trina and Brian’s
yells.
Loud cracking like something solid coming
apart, bits of rubble falling to the ground,
and the wet dripping sound of something thick
hitting the floor.
As the two rounded the corner to see what
was happening, to help their friends, Stella
froze in shock.
She had seen some harrowing things since that
fateful sunny day.
She almost thought she had become desensitized
to horror, that there was nothing left in
the world that could phase her.
But this moment proved her wrong.
There was so much to take in, and so little
time.
Brian was swinging his axe wildly at the floor,
chopping at it helplessly in an attempt to
break it apart.
It quickly became obvious why.
Trina was sinking into the floor, not through
a hole into the basement below but into the
floor itself.
It rippled and melted around her, changing
from a solid surface to a thick pool of black
sludge.
She flailed and struggled, grasping at the
ground around her, at Brian’s arm, anything
to yank herself free.
But she wouldn’t budge, she continued to
sink.
No…she wasn’t just sinking.
She was being pulled.
Stella felt her legs begin to work again,
and she rushed to Trina’s side, grabbing
hold of her arms with all the strength she
had.
All the while, Trina screamed in a mix of
desperation, terror, and pain.
Brian continued his assault on the ground,
as if he could cut her free from the floor,
and Doris moved to help Stella.
She grabbed ahold of Trina’s waist but stopped
suddenly.
There, at the place where her body vanished
into the floor, Trina was beginning to fall
apart.
Whatever had turned the floor into a portal,
whatever had rotted away at the walls, it
was taking its toll on her body too.
The flesh falling away from the bone, the
muscles liquifying, and everything being corrupted
by that same black mucus.
If they pulled any harder, Trina would be
ripped in two, her chest, arms, and head on
the surface while her legs, stomach, and most
of her vital organs were lost.
There was no way to save her.
Stella saw it when Doris did, and the two
shared a long, sad look.
Trina was here with them, still struggling
for her life, but she was already gone.
As if it felt their hopelessness, the force
pulling on Trina from below then gave the
horrifying yank they were praying to not have
to witness, and she was swallowed up by the
ground.
All that remained was a sticky black smear,
a large crack in the floor, and three survivors
where there had just been four.
None of the remaining three slept a wink that
night.
Brian paced back and forth, holding his axe.
Doris went over their supplies again, looking
for anything that could be used to treat the
effects of the corrosive black fluid.
And Stella ran over their potential options
again and again.
They could stay, and hope that the thing that
took Trina never came back.
Or they could leave and face the possibility
of succumbing to the sun or the influence
of the creatures that once were people.
She recalled dimly an old adage: The devil
you know beats the devil you don’t.
Maybe that was true, maybe it would be better
to take their chances with the outside rather
than stay and be hunted.
But she thought of her husband and children
again, watching them melt away onto the grass,
and she shuddered.
There were no good options here, but she couldn’t
risk going out like that.
They would stay.
Whatever had taken Trina, there were three
of them, and only one of it.
Besides, maybe it had already gotten what
it wanted, and now it would move on.
She didn’t know when she fell asleep, only
that when she eventually woke up, she was
alone.
Brian and Doris were nowhere to be found.
She called out their names as her heart leaped
into her throat.
For a moment, she feared the very worst.
But then, Brian answered her.
He had been patrolling, looking for signs
of trouble, but he was fine.
She asked if Doris was with him, and he went
pale.
He told Stella that Doris had gone to an on-site
bathroom to get cleaned up hours ago, before
he left.
She should have been back by then.
Without another thought, they took off toward
the bathroom and saw their worst fear realized.
The door to the room was gone, rotted away,
and Doris was gone with it.
She had been taken before she even had the
chance to scream.
They stood there, taking in the reality of
what had happened with silent shock.
Then, a sound from behind caused them to turn
around.
It was a raspy, hollowed-out sound, like air
forced from a dying man’s lungs.
A dry, empty, evil chuckle from an inhuman
throat.
There, they saw the creature that had stolen
their friends.
From a distance, Stella could have confused
it for a man, a very old, very sick man, but
still human.
As it shuffled closer, however, that illusion
was shattered.
Its eyes were black voids, its skin grey and
putrefied, its mouth a gaping toothless maw
of shriveled black gums.
And it was laughing at them.
Like it was enjoying itself.
There was the smell again, that overpowering
reek of all things foul.
Stella drew her pistol and fired several shots.
She didn’t have the best aim, especially
not when her hands were shaking with fear,
but one of the bullets found its target and
hit the creature in the cheek.
It hissed, not in pain, but a perverse amusement,
as the lead tore a hole through its flesh
like wet paper.
Globs of black blood spattered everywhere,
spreading the rot wherever they landed.
To her side, she heard Brian cry out in pain.
When she turned, he was clutching his right
eye.
Some of the liquid had hit him there, and
it was already taking effect.
Stella’s stomach turned as she saw something
white slide down the side of Brian’s face,
his eye melting out of its socket.
The skin around it followed suit, softening
like putty and dribbling away from the bloody
muscle underneath.
Brian collapsed to the floor, as the creature
continued to advance on them, laughing louder
and louder.
It knew that bullets couldn’t kill it.
Knew that there was nowhere to run.
Stella grabbed ahold of Brian’s arms, prepared
to carry her fallen friend to safety, but
he stopped her.
“I’m done for,” he said, quietly.
“If you try to carry me, you are too.”
She shook her head, unwilling to leave him
behind, and he touched her cheek, forcing
a smile on his decaying face.
“I didn’t think I’d make it this far.
I wouldn’t have without you.
So run, save yourself.”
She could hear the resignation in his voice
and knew that he would not let her save him.
“I’ll hold him off as long as I can,”
Brian promised, and, with tears in her eyes,
Stella turned and ran as fast as she could.
As her feet pounded the ground, blood rushing
in her ears, she could hear Brian screaming
and cursing at the creature until his voice
quickly faded to a wet gurgle, and then, silence.
Stella sat in the center of the room that
she and the others had once shared, clutching
her scavenged pistol in her hands.
Every creak, every errant sound made her jump.
It could be anywhere.
Come from anywhere.
She had escaped from so much already, survived
more than anyone was ever meant to.
Had lost her love, her friends, her home…she
wouldn’t lose herself too.
She held her breath as she heard it, clear
in the darkness: Drip.
Drip.
Her grip on the weapon tightened, and she
readied herself.
If she had to go down, she might as well go
down swinging.
The Old Man, whether he was a man, a monster,
or death itself, wouldn’t be taking her
anywhere…not without a fight.
Now go check out “SCP-106 - The Old Man
Tale - Until Death” and “SCP-001 - When
Day Breaks” for more on The Old Man, and
what happens to the world when the sun turns
against humanity.